dude there's this [ __ ] person next to
me the whole movie who just wouldn't
stop talking and he would do that kind
of talking or he's pointing out what's
going on with the screen he's a computer
and then he would take his slurpee and
then bang it like this all the time and
then drink out of it so loud where it's
like dude you don't have any more
slurpee left this movie's complicated i
get was going on he's a computer and
stuff he wasn't Mexican cut that out Lou
um Ryan right and i'm gerry welcome two
reasons to see when we give you reasons
to see and maybe not to see
transcendence so you and I are gonna
hang out I was my impression of your
impression first time I've been so it
was not very good you know what the
first video we ever posted was actually
a video called hilarious Johnny Depp
impression it has more dislikes than
like so it's not that hilarious so we're
your day to talk about transcendence
some spoiler talk is what we're gonna do
if you haven't seen transparency you
want to see some non-spoiler reviews you
check out mine right here and you can
check out Jerry's right here but here's
where we come together it's like a
[ __ ] Avengers review right now yeah
same comparison this movie is getting
some horrible feedback it kind of I mean
pretty bad dude well the numbers are bad
that's why i hate Rotten Tomatoes
sometimes because it's like nineteen
percent is very deceptive if you read a
lot of those capsules a lot of them are
like it doesn't have enough to pay off
all of its ideas but it's not terrible
like November like this is shitty yeah
that's well I'll give you that but still
it has like a nineteen percent that is
low yeah that's all I'm rating but
that's what I'm saying is like that's
the problem with those kinds of services
is like it makes people go oh that must
be [ __ ] and then they don't read any
further well we're not here to talk
about Rotten Tomatoes Jerry we're here
to talk about this movie I personally
really thought it was cool i love the
concept of it the concept to me was
brilliant
hooking up your mind to an artificial
intelligence computer that's a [ __ ]
sweet gone said man the evolution of
everything that he was doing from like
healing people to like give you them
super strength and then being able to I
mean it got a little bit absurd like
controlling the weather and [ __ ] like
that yeah cuz they bring in
nanotechnology and stuff like that I
mean it goes a lot of places it's one of
those ideas that has I'm sure when when
they were beating out the script it was
like wow we could take this a million
different directions you know yeah but I
liked upfront was seen Johnny Depp again
I love seeing Johnny Depp he's one of
those actors here about being a movie or
Lego Johnny Depp again like I love him a
lot he's actually one of my favorite
actors when I saw the trailer I was like
ok he's just playing a normal dude but
they may I saw him like he's got that
star presence man when it's nice to see
him in a movie where he's you know not
wacky yeah where he's not playing a jack
sparrow s character you know it's like
oh you're back in more of a dramatic
turn again and I bought him right up
front has his carrot although he did
have this moment in the beginning where
he does like a weird laugh and then he's
like haha you're lying I like was I what
focus for that that bid for me Johnny
Depp in this movie he almost felt a
little bit rusty to me rusty yeah like I
don't know there was something I
believed him less easily at least up
front that I did not so much later on
when he become when when they upload his
mind and everything I bought it more
looks a little weird when Johnny Depp
doesn't put on a voice and changes those
appearance oh yeah I would say that's
what he's weird like is this just
different now and I'm yeah I'm having
trouble adjusting to it or do I not
understand his choices and these [ __ ]
glasses I just got glass very dedicated
yeah and they just keep [ __ ] a
fogging up man it's pissing me off pull
them down your face yeah maybe they're
too close smash them right in New I love
the whole transgression that happens for
Johnny Depp you know he gets shot it but
poisoning the bullet so he's now
deteriorating slowly and I think he
really shave it he must have really
shave his head it looked like you would
have think you would have saw it seemed
like some stills online though of him
like with a shaved head like walking
around or something maybe I mean it's
not the kind of movie that they I think
they would just incessantly release
things for though you know yeah it's not
the amazing spider-man 2 Oh like someone
sneezed on set cheer check it out yeah
well when he becomes the computer
I love that moment where yeah he's like
re hello is anyone that like that was so
cool my big did it even up in the
trailer they totally reveal it yeah it
sounds gonna go I mean that's that's
just the setup you know I heard they
film this they put Johnny Depp actually
like in some type of room and they kind
of like skyped him on the computer so
Rebecca Hall could play off of him it's
cool yeah i'm rebecca hall though she's
she's like the star of this movie for
sure Jeff's the one who's advertise all
over the screen but Rebecca Hall she has
the real emotional performance here she
has a whole character art there her
whole confusion she goes through because
you know they do that thing where it's
like it's really cool at first that he's
a computer like she's escaping and [ __ ]
I love when he's like saying I really
saw the security cameras at the anti
terrorist group so that way they could
all just capture that he like loads up
her [ __ ] bank account so that asked
money in their mother [ __ ] yeah it's
great how much you get [ __ ] like million
dollar bottle yeah she's got a lot of
money it's cool because you're like he's
getting it away with it because there's
he controls the old Internet yeah there
are times when I had trouble believing
that no one would be like hang on a
minute like that's not true kate mara
was like hey they made a lot of money in
24 hours I'm surprised that nobody out
like the people who whose money was
taken and put into her account ya know
and like the whole thing where the FBI
is like someone solving all these cases
for us somehow I guess we'll just take
that out yeah we're not gonna check and
see who has breached our security system
to help us out word isn't gonna go with
it hey I will say that there are some
definite flaws like one thing I pointed
out was out the tone of this movie is
kind of weird because it starts off at a
reasonable pace and then it gets a
little bit more intense and fast and
then when they go to like the small town
to rebuild and stuff and it starts to
slow down it slows down a lock you know
it takes time for character moments it
takes time for things because you know
and that moment in the movie that's when
things are being built and developing so
it kind of makes sense for it to slow
down even though people are complaining
about it I adjusted to it cuz I was like
well at this point in the story it makes
sense to take your time war it's not
like a hyper fast-paced flash bang you
know sci-fi no not at all action
thriller so much you know it's it's a
little bit more intellectually inclined
even if it doesn't always hit its mark I
guess yeah but you can't deny the fact
this movies full of great moments you
know there's devil i mean i like this
movie
I know there's a lot of great stuff in
there especially you know Rebecca Hall I
mean she sort of gives this movie a very
human core Paul Bettany to it's great
right like when he gets captured by the
terrorist group and then he becomes one
of them and I was like it makes perfect
sense why he becomes one of them you
know is it it was a very believable
switch I liked his character a lot
because he's like one of the main
reasons you find a debate going on as
well yeah even though I with the whole
time I was like I'm totally on Johnny
Depp side I thought we'd try it out was
doing was [ __ ] awesome like he's
saving the world right now this is great
but of course everyone the movies like
we gotta kill this computer even though
he hasn't really done anything that bad
well I don't know if it's because that
is because of like what they know we
don't know exactly what you're doing and
and it's like you know when he starts
healing all those people and they become
super strong it's like a lot characters
looked at that and when things could go
very wrong and we wouldn't be I am to
fix this especially when he's like
jacket into their brain and controlling
their bodies yeah it's like one is too
much access to much excess yeah but it's
cool man they like created a god and
that's like the theme of this movie
haven't we always done the creative
goods I love that moment where there was
a construction worker dude yeah he gets
like his ass kicked and then like they
completely heal his body great effects
in that scene and great [ __ ] moment
overall all those healing scenes I
thought were awesome like the blind guy
they put the [ __ ] needle in his eyes
and you can see I'm like this is why we
need this damn computer program good
well that's me i mean there's a whole
subplot about nanotechnology in here and
that stuff that they are actually
working yeah i heard that that are
actually pretty close to completing
technology like this like loading your
consciousness into a computer but that's
different saying the stuff that he's
using to like yeah but i'm still saying
that they're doing that jerry i know but
i think you're confusing the computer
program like I'm not I know you're
talking about something different all
right I just brought up a different
point ok anyway continue it was neat
then to see like oh here's a visual
representation of how nanotechnology
taken to a certain extreme might look
when it worked the ending of this film
okay I thought it was so cool Wow Johnny
Depp returns and he's a human now and oh
man that
look that Rebecca Hall gives of because
she's like ready to like turn him in and
stuff and like I become the virus and
destroy him and then when she sees him
it was such a beautifully acted moment
Oh to love like oh my god you're a lot
that was so raw you know like the inner
conflict that she's feeling I was
starting to feel that too like yeah you
could finally bone this guy you should
probably keep him alive you know it's
all about sex it's all about sex it does
make compelling arguments and it gives
you enough points of view from both
sides of the equation to make you
actually want to think about it
sometimes Kate Mara's character I didn't
I didn't really fully believe her
performance at times she's hot as [ __ ]
but at the same time I was like is gonna
off about your performance around the
time of her hair changed I was a little
more intermittent on believing her yeah
yeah that's true a lot there's really
not much more you can say about this
movie it's like your guys are gonna like
it or dislike you know there's not much
more because I see why critics are
saying what they're saying but at the
same time I'm like you're being a little
too harsh at the end of this day this
movie is very imaginative it goes to
places another movie hasn't gone to
before if it's brave in a lot of ways
you know it's very courageous it's not
lazy I mean it like it does there are
certain times where it doesn't fill in
certain plot gaps and that kind of takes
away from it but it's got a lot of
interesting ideas got a lot of really
beautiful moments it gives you something
to think about yeah it's entertaining
still the end of day for being
entertained that's what really counts
when you watch a [ __ ] movie so yeah
it's a good flick yeah it shoots really
high it doesn't necessarily hit the mark
but it hits its good it round well it's
good enough so what would you say are
some reasons to see jer bear oh man
drove take the first one cuz i can't
remember rebecca hall yeah you're
[ __ ] awesome Rebecca fantastic you're
great another reason to see puppet named
Paul Bettany we had a debate earlier
about who's more popular jennifer
connelly or paul bettany comment below
and let us know number three you know he
does become like a robot but Johnny Depp
I actually did like him in this film I
like toast when he was a robot really I
liked him as a human when he was just a
regular human being too I like that part
but I really like that oh that is
something i got to say about Johnny Depp
was that they created this character
who you're like everyone's like oh he's
the bad guy now but I liked him a lot
because he does employ like of an evil
machine now you get where he's coming
from you can still feel the humanity
behind all his motivation and intent I
thought he they developed that character
really well when he was the computer
well he's not even a bad guy that I mean
that's part of the debate at the movie
is this good or bad isn't this
reasonable or not you know and and of
course he doesn't believe it because
he's not a bad guy but the portrayal of
it was like yeah there wasn't like
trying to lead you down this path of you
know he just played it like yeah cuz I
human became a computer yeah ya know
exactly it's like the movie treats it
from both sides it's like some people
were for this some people are against it
it's their ways in which it's good in
their ways in which it's not you know
absolutely reason to see number four uh
you know it is really well shot yes
cinematography great it's great to look
at shot by a jess jess something guys
the guy to did hot fuzz and stuff number
five I would have to say the effects are
pretty damn good there's some great
effects in this felt it's not bombarded
with effects but when they effects are
there they're pretty damn sweet bid
amount and uh ya know probably the main
reasons to see it mm-hmm you know we
haven't done in a while reasons not to
see no reason not to see reasons not to
see plot holes yeah it's got some puzzle
maybe some of the pacing yeah pacing or
done alright guys checking out review
for transcendence once you go ahead
stroll that comment box below and tell
us what's your favorite thing to look
online except for porn and then once
you're done with that come over here
click this button so you can see more
accessories and last but not least if
you want to get updated a bit some
wonderful reviews of it yeah I don't
know what that was yeah subscribe people
click that button you know it would be
so cool to get hooked up to a computer
after I you know like when I'm on my way
out yeah they can like I want to do that
I hope by the time I'm about to die that
they can hook my brain up to a computer
yeah that'd be awesome dude all the porn
in the world Ryan book pro have you also
i would talk with so many people if you
guys like the fact that i call me back
now imagine what I'm a consciousness
computer well yeah then then you would
be like her it's like I'm having 64
million conversations right now
be so sweet to just talk it so many
people at once her was cool that
scarlett johansson sexy ass voice dude
johnny depp with no facial hair after a
very long time is he a facial or in this
movie um okay Bibble yeah like he just
shaved a few days at the end he looked
like from public enemies he did right
yeah the same stuff like it's john
dillinger yeah he picked his favorite
Johnny Depp movie to come back at ya one
of the least responsive films life over
again music I don't watch porn